now we're ready to start hooking up our
components into circuits and one of the
two things that are going to be very
useful to us are Kirchhoff's laws and in
this video we're going to talk about
Kirchhoff's voltage law if we look at
this circuit here this is a voltage
source let's just say this is this is
ten volts and we'll put a resistor
connected to it and let's say the
resistor is 200 ohms just for something
to talk about one of the things I can do
here is I can I can label this with
voltages on the different nodes here's
one node down here I'm going to
arbitrarily call this zero volts and
then if I go through this voltage source
this node this node up here that is
going to be at 10 volts 10 volts so
here's a little bit of jargon we call
this voltage here the voltage goes up as
we go through the voltage source and
that's called a voltage rise and over on
this side if we are standing at this
point in the circuit right here and we
went from this node down to this node
like that
the voltage would go from 10 volts down
to zero volts in this circuit and that's
called a voltage drop that's just a
little bit of slang or jargon that we
use to talk about changes in voltage now
I can make an observation about this if
I if I look at this voltage rise here
it's 10 volts and if I look at that
voltage drop the drop is 10 volts I can
say the drop is 10 volts or I can say
the rise on this side is minus 10 volts
a rise of minus 10 these two these two
expressions mean exactly the same thing
it meant that the voltage went from 10
volts to zero volts sort of going
through this 200 ohm resistor so I write
a little expression for this which is V
rise minus v2
op equals what equals zero I went I went
up 10 volts back down 10 volts I end up
back at 0 volts that's this right here
and this is a form of kirchoff's voltage
law it says the voltage Rises minus the
voltage drops is equal to zero so if we
just plug our actual numbers in here
what we just what we get is 10 minus 10
equals zero I'm going to draw this
circuit again let's draw another version
of this circuit and this time we'll have
two resistors instead of one and we'll
make it whoops
we'll make it to 100 ohm resistors and
let's go through and label these this is
again 10 volts so this note is at zero
volts this node is at 10 volts what's
this note this note here is these are
equal resistors so this is going to be
at 5 volts that's this node voltage here
with respect to here so that is 5 volts
this is 5 volts
and this is 10 volts so let's just do
our tower visit again let's start here
and count the rises and drops okay we go
up 10 volts then we have a voltage drop
of 5 and we have another voltage drop of
5 and then we get back to 0 we can write
the sum of the Rises and the Falls just
like we did before we can say 10 volts
minus 5 minus 5 equals zero all right so
I can generalize this we can say this in
general we can do the summation that's
the summation symbol of the V rise minus
the sum of the V fall equals 0 this is a
form of Kirchhoff's voltage law the sum
of the voltage Rises minus the sum of
the voltage Falls is always equal to 0
there's a more compact way to write this
that I like better and that is we start
at this corner we start at any corner of
the of the circuit let's say let's say
we start here we're going to go up 10
volts down 5 volts and down 5 volts so
what we're adding is the voltage Rises
we're adding all the voltage Rises rise
plus 10 that's a rise of minus 5 and a
rise of minus 5 so I can write this with
just one summation symbol
the voltages around the loop where I
takes us all the way around the loop
equals zero so this means I start hit
any place on the circuit go around in
some direction this way or this way up
down down and I end up back at the same
voltage I started at so let's put a box
around that - this is kvl kirchoff's
voltage law now I started over here in
this corner but I could start anywhere
if I started at the top and went around
around clockwise if I started here say I
would go minus 5 minus 5 plus 10 and I
get the same answer I'd still get back
to zero if I start here and I go around
the other way same thing happens plus 5
rise plus 5 rise and this is a 10 volt
drop so it works whichever way you go
around the loop and it works for
whatever whatever node you start at
that's the essence of Kirchhoff's
voltage law we're going to pair this
with the current law Kirchhoff's current
law and with those two that's our tools
for doing circuit analysis